نجمه الصمود الاوكراني كما وصفت دعمت عمود
المساعدات الغربيه العسكري وصنعت الفارقه
في الحرب لا سيما ان استخدامها جاء من
الطرفين لتحديد مواقع العدو وتوجيه نيران
المدفعيه نحوها
على اعتاب كييف كانت المسيرات الاوكرانيه
اول من اقفل الباب بوجه القوات الروسيه
لتسحب ذيولها خلال ساعات وتتفرق شرقا
وجنوبا فيما الخاصره اي شبه جزيره القرم
التي زرعت الشوكه الروسيه فيها منذ تسع
سنوات تتعرض كل حين لهجمات بالمسيرات
هدفها الاولي قطع امداد المعدات والغذاء
عن موسكو واستهداف اسطول البحر الاسود
الروسي في سيفا ستوبول
جيش الدرون الاوكراني الذي قلل من اضرار
التفوق الروسي حجما وقدره شمل بدايه
مسيرات تجاريه رخيصه الثمن صينيه الصنع دي
جي اي مافيك حضرت صادراتها بكين لاحقا على
اعتبار انها للاستخدام المدني فقط لكن
مسيرات بيرقدار التركيه شكلت العين
الاساسيه على اوكار الخصومه تحمل كاميرات
استطلاعيه ويمكن تسليحها بقنابل موجهه
بالليزر واستخدمت بالهجوم الذي اغرق سفينه
موسكفا الروسيه في ابريل 2022 لكن هذه
المسيرات يعيبها حجمها الكبير وببطء
حركتها وسهوله اسقاطها مقارنه بكمكاز
الانتحاريه فالعصافير القاتله او الذخيره
المتسكعه تتميز بقدرتها على التحليق في
منطقه الهدف المحدد مسبقا وتضرب عند
التعرف الى العدو تطلق من مسافات بعيده
ويصعب اكتشافها لصغر حجمها اهميه هذا
السلاح ادركته موسكو سريعا فاندفعت الى
ايران لشراء مسيرات انتحاريه عمياء بدقه
ضعيفه استخدمتها لاول مره في خركيف ثم
كياف واوداسا وميكولياف غير ان هذه
المسيرات لم ترقى لتوقعات الروس واخفقت
كثيرا وفق واشنطن لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات